these people are working to safeguard
democracy in lebanon ahead of the
elections on sunday they are making the
final preparations to ensure that the
electoral process is fair and
transparent
and that's not an easy task in a deeply
polarized country where sectarian
loyalty is the perhaps the leading
driving force for people when casting
their wards
the lebanese association for democratic
elections or lady is largely funded by
european countries
diana al-baba is responsible for
coordinating and overseeing all
activities of the association
and she believes that corruption is also
hurting democracy in lebanon
we have some sort of clientelistic
relationship between the voters and
their mps and their candidates
if i give you money you have to vote for
me
or i don't give you this money i can
provide you a service by being by
inserting you by appointing you
in a certain position in the public
sector
if you don't vote for me
i will you'll not get this job
lebanon has been subjected to chronic
political instability for the last
several years that led to large-scale
demonstrations against the political
elite ultimately forcing the government
to resign
in the following year a devastating
explosion at port of beirut killed 2018
people further deteriorating the already
crippled economy and deepening the
political instability
the elections on sunday are being seen
by many as a litmus test for real change
and affords are on the way to avoid
fraud violations and irregularities
the minister of interior is in charge of
ensuring the transparency of these
elections
we trust the lebanese people and our
security forces we will observe every
detail during the election day it is our
people's right to have a transparent
election that their voice and decision
is the ultimate power the law will be in
place for those who try to violate the
rules
however there is a deep mistrust in
state institutions including the
judiciary as most people believe they
are all deeply pulsized
despite a series of measures taken by
the interior ministry serious concerns
remain about possible violations of the
electoral process people here say there
is no real deterrence mechanism to
prevent irregularities and as in lebanon
political parties have rarely been held
accountable for their actions there is
little hope that this time will be
different
al jazeera beirut